you might not think of the hunger games
as a cgi heavy movie
but in reality so much of it was
actually animation
in order to create the dystopian
landscape of pan m
teams of hundreds of different animators
worked tirelessly on all four movies
remember those huge crowds watching
caesar on stage in the capital
all cgi today we're checking out some of
the most
amazing computer animated moments from
all four hunger games movies
going back to the first two hunger games
movies one of the coolest examples of
some seriously
impressive cgi has got to be the control
room
from which the game maker controls and
manipulates the entire arena to drive
the tributes closer together
and generally make their lives as hard
as possible in order to achieve the
super futuristic look described in the
books they built a set that was almost
entirely covered
in green screen they then taught all of
the background actors a series of
movements to use to make it look as
though they were actually
operating holographic computer screens
which were animated in later
it probably goes as a general rule when
making a movie that
the less you have to light people on
fire for real the better
especially when the people in question
are two of the biggest movie stars
in the entire world so when it came to
the spectacular set of fire wings that
cinna made for both katniss and peeta to
show off on their chariot ride during
the opening ceremony
those were also computer generated no
director wants to be the person who lit
jennifer lawrence on fire
so that was a pretty good call tribute
we welcome you while the films were shot
in a handful
of real-life locations including atlanta
georgia charlotte north carolina hawaii
and even paris
the capitol itself doesn't actually
exist
so if you're planning a hunger games
sightseeing trip into the rocky
mountains to look for the center of pan
am
you might find yourself out of luck they
actually used huge green screens and
took inspiration from multiple locations
around europe to create the capital
using animation they referenced a few
different styles of architecture in
order to create a place that looked
incredibly intimidating but also a
little familiar
all of the hunger games movies feature
some seriously
huge crowd scenes and the extravagant
opening ceremony has got to be one of
the most impressive
inspired by the ancient chariot races
and gladiator battles of ancient rome
the tributes are cheered on by thousands
of capital citizens sitting in the
stands
except almost none of those citizens
were actually there
they were all added in later by
animators which is a whole lot cheaper
and
far easier than hiring placing and
costuming
thousands of background actors so
clearly
are able to reflect the character of
each district
everyone who's seen the hunger games
might be pretty glad to find out that
the giant and terrifying mutts that
chased peta and katniss through the
woods
were actually totally animated cgi
artists used the descriptions from the
books to painstakingly bring the
creatures to life
and they did an amazing job the finished
mutts look a little bit like steroid
using rottweilers
whose faces have been smushed with a
frying pan
and are not something we want to run
into in real life there was no debate
about the fact that whoever scored the
role of katniss would have to train hard
to believably pull off some of the
incredible archery that the character's
capable of
and jennifer lawrence did just that she
trained with a five-time
olympic archer for 15 hours in order to
nail the sport
and most archery experts agree but she
nailed it
but when it came to actually shooting
arrows on camera
the production actually decided it would
be a lot safer to animate
all of her arrows for the safety of
everyone on set
she's not even afraid of us one of the
most heartbreaking moments from the
second hunger games movie
catching fire was the scene in which
peta and katniss pay a visit to district
11.
if you know the franchise you knew that
district 11 was rue's district
so this particular visit was devastating
for katniss
what you might not have realized about
the relatively simple scene
is that much of it was animated from the
screens playing images of roo's face
to the size of the crowd and the
location itself
we like to donate one month of our
winnings to the families of the tributes
every year for the rest of our lives as
katniss and peeta continue their
victor's tour of all the districts
it becomes clear that the unrest they
sparked during the games is spreading
across pan
am in one instance the gathered crowd
becomes upset by their lack of action
against the capital
and rushed the stage before katniss and
peeta are rushed off to safety
even though this scene seems like it
would be easy enough to do with a crowd
of real people
the digital effects artists actually
used a small group
and multiplied it over and over in order
to make the crowd even bigger
katniss's home district district 12 is
one of the poorest in
all of pan am 12 is also responsible for
providing
coal to the capital so it's all centered
around huge mines that most citizens
work in
day in and day out while there are
plenty of mining towns throughout the
u.s
what you see in the film is you guessed
it cgi
rather than building giant cranes and
oil rigs they simply
shot in front of a blue screen and added
them in afterwards
the tributes from district 12.
one of the most action-packed sequences
from mockingjay part 2
is definitely the chase scene inside the
berlin metro station between the capitol
peacekeepers and katniss
and the star squad during this scene we
get to see some
seriously cool cgi moments one of these
moments occurs when a member of the star
squad
runs underneath a circular beam of light
and is
shattered into a million pieces it is a
very sad moment for the rebels
but an amazing piece of animation the
beams of exploding light weren't the
only impressive effects to use during
that sequence either
as this next one demonstrates just how
much cgi can enhance a movie in ways
that practical effects just
can't quite pull off during the same
metro fight just as we thought the
rebels were almost on their way to
safety the entire floor starts exploding
underneath their feet
and all they can do is try and outrun it
before it swallows them
it was a huge task bringing these
beloved books to life on the big screen
there were some moments that the
filmmakers knew the fans were going to
be waiting for
and katniss's flaming dress during the
opening ceremony was
definitely one of them and it didn't
disappoint
but fortunately for jennifer lawrence
they didn't actually light her on fire
for the sake of the movie
all of the flames you see erupting from
her stunning red dress were actually cgi
that was something that was something
thank you for that
there are many things in the hunger
games that we are
very glad don't actually exist in real
life
and on the top of that list are the
tracker jackers
designed to look like giant genetically
modified hornets
these terrifying creatures look way too
real during the scene when katniss
knocks one of their nests out of a tree
after being chased up by an
all-too-eager group of hunger games
tributes
when we first visit district 13 one of
the most impressive parts of it
is their giant underground weapons
facility
almost the entire thing was animated
even though they did build some
very realistic looking nuclear weapons
to go inside it
because it would be almost impossible to
find a location
that was as big as district 13 needed to
be
it was a whole lot easier to shoot it on
a blue screen and bring it up to scale
using cgi
quick introductions catas these people
come a long way
while the hunger games movies had a
pretty huge budget
it wasn't quite enough to cover the
building of a futuristic military-level
hovercraft
so the very impressive one that we see
rise up out of the floor and mockingjay
part 1
was in fact animated
yeah that's a mockingjay honestly the
effects in the hunger games are so
amazing that we might never have known
that none of it was real
what about you let us know what you
thought about this video in the comments
and don't forget to hit subscribe to
keep up with
all of our latest videos